since the late 1920s everything we know
about how our universe works has been
turned upside down it's important to
realize how much our picture of the
universe has changed in the last century
at the beginning of the 20th century the
conventional wisdom in science was that
the universe was static and eternal in
1929 that all changed at the Mount
Wilson Observatory above Los Angeles
astronomer Edwin Hubble discovered
galaxies aren't stuck in one place not
only are they moving but they're flying
away from Earth at incredible speeds
this was the first real evidence of the
Big Bang
all galaxies on average are moving away
from us and strangers still those that
were twice as far away we're winning
twice as fast and those that were three
times as far away we're moving three
times as fast and so on everything was
moving away from us it became known as
Hubble's law his discovery is still the
starting point for exploration of the
Big Bang what Hubble convincingly
demonstrated by seeing the motion of
those galaxies is that the universe is
expanding
theoretically an expanding universe must
have started from a single point by
measuring how fast the universe is
expanding astronomers calculated
backwards and figured out when it bursts
into life people ask the question how do
you know that the universe is 13.7
billion years old I mean smartypants you
weren't there
13.7 billion years ago well when you
watch television on videotape you hit
the stop button when you see an
explosion and you could run it backwards
and see when it actually took place the
same thing takes place with cosmology we
can run the videotape backwards and then
calculate plane and all came from a
cosmic explosion